ahmed khalaf has been writing about the
momentous and often
violent changes iraq has suffered for
more than half a century
the baghdad-based author whose novels
short stories and poems
have been published across the arab
world has had to navigate censorship
political imprisonment and even death
threats throughout his career
he acknowledges his contribution to
iraqi literature but he is
saddened by what he says is the lack of
impact
his work has had
the country has culturally regressed
people who don't read or write might
struggle to develop
culture across the arab world is
suffering terribly and arab writers too
without freedom to write how can others
learn i feel have little effect on
people's thoughts
the book shops along elmo tanabe street
named after a 10th century poet
have been immortalized in iraqi and arab
culture for centuries
the crumbling ottoman buildings have
witnessed how the pressures on iraqi
writers
and readers have changed over the years
the challenge of avoiding jail or worse
under the rule of saddam hussein
to bomb attacks and kidnapping by
al-qaeda isil
and various armed groups that still have
much power
in iraq tanabe street has almost a
mythical status
in the history of arabic literature a
place where writers and intellectuals
would meet
to discuss politics and the arts
but despite the political instability
and violence that this country continues
to suffer there is increasing evidence
of young writers appearing who are
determined not to self-censor
and to protect and build on iraq's
literary past
is a young recently published iraqi poet
she owns a book shop and one of a number
of recently opened publishing houses
close by
she says half the books in her shop are
by new
young iraqi writers we're trying to wake
people up from their hibernation for too
long iraqis have accepted what we were
told
so as young writers we try to stimulate
minds without religion
or focus on ethnicity instead we look at
a reader's humanity
we're not afraid because we have seen so
much of course i sometimes worry about
my family but we have to re-stimulate
ideas of civilized things at baghdad's
annual international book fair young
people who can afford to
buy books including arabic literature
history philosophy
and translated foreign works
it is difficult for our generation to
find the correct road to walk along
so we depend on ourselves and through
books and reading
i hope we can change the next generation
to plant flowers not thorns
that we find on the path we travel along
we have to read more widely to forge a
new future
young people here definitely seem keen
to read
hope at least that iraq's literary
heritage is being rekindled by a new
generation
who say their country's future stability
and growth will be helped by young
iraqis
reading and writing more charles
stratford al jazeera
baghdad